字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
字幕志愿者 李宗盛有聽到聲音吗?哦,有听到声音,加个1啊
有听到声音,加个1,加个1
各位晚上好,晚安
夜盘往上拉,哎呀,刚刚低点我有买
看一下看一下,有往上拉,看拉了几点
現在夜盤呢都大幅震盪
都大幅震盪
所以呢
急殺就是讓你買的啦
常常急殺讓你買
急掌呢讓你賣
夜盤常常都這樣
還好啦
也算是有拉到
變成4615
那明天呢是這個
我先賣一下
明天是這個台子旗呢
明天是台積電法說啦
明天是台積電法說
有沒有聽到聲音
有沒有
聲音可以喔
明天是台積電法說
所以明天會蠻刺激的
來看一下台積電法說的狀況
來我們給各位看
各股事件獲利王
這樣應該大聲了吧
還是要再近一點
應該可以再近一點
這樣子
這樣大聲喔
欸
我們家的
火鍋肉質很占便宜又只會
這樣這個
欸等一下等一下我已經弄到最大聲了
最大聲我看一下我看一下麥克風
麥克風屬性
對啊
呃
沒沒
沒有放錯
這個沒有錯
沒有大聲聲音OK啊
有聲音啊聲音OK啊
有素菜鍋嗎有
有素菜鍋
有興趣可以去吃
有素菜鍋可以吃
好那各位呢這個
來看一下最近的台積電的法說會啦
台積電法說會呢
這法說會呢在什麼時候
在明天
明天有台積電法說
哎呦 也有鴻海的法說
也有百合的法說
那這個
7月份的法說呢
7月份法說呢在2025年齁7月份法說是這個平盤開出跌了2%齁 然後呢在2024年呢是
2%開出漲了7% 哇賽
這很誇張齁
2%開出漲了7%
那2023年呢是
平盤開出 平盤收盤
24年比較激情
然後呢21年呢是
21年是1%開出這個收黑
然後呢19年呢
19年
這邊怎麼離一張
19年就比較普通
所以呢這邊
法說會呢這邊有一些7月份的統計
那其實法說會呢1470最重要
1470最重要
那今年的法說會已經兩次了
來看一下 今年的法說會兩次
一次呢是
唉呦 喔 喔 百合的喔 按錯了
按錯了 哈哈哈哈
原來是按錯了 難怪覺得怪怪的
法說會那麼少
好 來來來 原來是按錯了 台積電這裡
台積電法說25年的呢
是漲2%開出呢
平盘开出涨2%
收盘涨2%
那24年呢
跌1%开出呢
后面变跌3%
哎呦,有点惨
然后23年呢,是跌3%开出,跌3%
跌3%开出,跌3%
那22年呢,是涨1%开出
变成涨3%
二年這樣喔
那21年呢
是跌3%之後跌4%
所以呢7月份的法書位
其實
其實也是蠻刺激的啦
20年呢是平盤開出
漲這個
2.66%
所以法書位很刺激嘛
法書位很刺激
所以就會怎麼樣
也會影響到那個
這個權證也會影響到選擇權
會影響到選擇權喔
這個各位啊
明天法說會晚呢
夜盤可能就會有指數的反應就有指數反應喔指數可能就漲或大跌所以明天盤中你有空你就可以去買一下
這個選擇權
因為夜盤可能就有反應了
那你要買選擇權
哪一個選擇權呢
他的反應會最激烈
明天反應最激烈的就是
那個
周五的選擇權
因為明天周四
所以周五選擇權呢,他的反應呢會最激烈
那台建法說呢,你也可以玩權證啦
各位呢,法說也可以玩權證
那玩權證記得去買那個
呃,插槓比比較低的
插槓比低
然後呢,槓桿比較大
槓桿比較大的喔,槓桿比較大的蠻有趣的喔
槓桿比較大的,我們來看,這也太大了吧
但是這個已經
這個一翻兩瞪眼了啦
这个你明天买完呢
你明天买完就怎么样
你明天买完就结算了
就结算了齁
明天买完就没办法进出了
这一档是明天买完没办法进出
所以买完之后
礼拜五
这个不能交易
因为7月20号
可以看一下7月20号
7月20号到期啦
那两天前呢最后交易日
所以明天這一檔槓桿很高
但是呢 你買完之後就怎麼樣
就結算了
買完之後進結算
進決算就憑人品了啦
因為剛好他的履約價呢 非常的接近
剛好是今天的唯買價
剛好是唯買價喔
然後呢 這個
這一檔喔 這一檔很有意思啦
這檔很有意思
你可以用一色表呢
跑一下
這檔呢可以用一色表
我跑給各位看
這檔是這樣子
各位你看一下他的
他的這個履約價
履約價呢是2435.53
行之比例0.04
2435.53
就這樣子
那你假如要算他的結算價呢
欸我教各位算
結算價呢等於2500-2435-53
然後呢我們把它括號一下
這邊呢給他加個絕對值
加個錢
摳住
再乘以這個b
加個錢
摳住
就這樣子
這可以算出什麼東西啊
這可以算出他的內涵價值
內涵價值啦
好啦
所以你買這一檔
小數點不要太多
不要太多
你買這一檔 漲到2600他就變成6塊5
現在才1塊8
漲到2600變6塊5啦
漲到2600有沒有可能
有可能
其實有可能
漲到2600就3倍了
2435以下就歸零
所以你明天買這一檔
這邊全部都時間價值
全部都時間價值喔
這裡都全部時間價值
所以買這檔很刺激的喔
所以你看一下 你買這一檔 哇塞
每天流失時間價值 流失超多啊
每天流失300多塊
事實上應該不止啦
但是越到後面 它時間價值會越來越大
那這檔很刺激啦
那這種法說會這麼刺激的
欸
還27倍槓桿的喔 真的還蠻少見的
剩下的槓桿呢 沒那麼大
那我們來看一下槓桿比較大
法術會呢 就是玩一個槓桿大的
槓桿大的法術會呢 它的重點是喔
它還那個 漲跌不對等
那這邊幾個呢 都不能碰了
剩下這檔還可以碰
其他的插槓比都太大了
插槓比大你也沒辦法玩
買不到嘛
XX比大 例如說XX比5%
5%你漲5%才會賺
所以根本沒得玩
所以槓桿大呢
哇 就這一檔欸
其他沒什麼好玩的欸
這邊難得還有另外一檔
剩8倍槓桿
好 結算就要履約還是
花錢去買股票
履約他會幫你算價差就好
喔999代表說怎麼樣
代表說他沒有賣價啦
所以差甘比無窮大99旅約到了他就直接付差價給你差甘比99你不用管他啦他就是一個沒有買賣價的狀況沒有買賣價999啦
沒有買賣價99
聲音太小
我看一下聲音
我看一下我這邊的聲音
全部都時間價了喔
我的手機聽聲音是蠻大聲的
好所以呢台電明天法說呢
各位 全震看起來是沒有幾檔好全震啊
因為台積電的波動率
31%
然後現在的隱含波動率
各位來看一下
現在的隱含波動率呢
它的買賣隱波都變大了
現在很多隱含波動率呢
買賣隱波都變大
所以導致台積電的槓桿都沒有那麼漂亮了
台積電的槓桿都沒那麼漂亮
所以呢這個
各位就
這個你可以用全證
或是選擇權
好那一開始請各位加一下這幾個QRコン
這個PressPlay的
九折優惠券
還有Taggren粉絲團
Taggren跟粉絲團呢公告一些注意事項
Night呢各位有問題可以在上面問
官方社團有交易知識
YouTube教學影片
IG呢IG有這個
會PO一些當中的點位圖
那我昨天呢就跟
就跟宣講那個台虹有噎到的隔日沖啦
台虹有噎到的隔日沖
所以呢
昨天講台虹噎到隔日沖啦
所以我今天我就做台虹
今天做台虹
所以我教的就是我做的
我教的就是我做的
空一空之後跌下來
這邊我是用期貨空
這段用期貨空
好
來
哇
那學員說
給我看一下
小哥
家的火鍋
打個廣告了
小哥家火鍋真的很讚
停車或許不方便
其實現在停車很方便
在火鍋店前大概30公尺
就有一個停車廠
上面沒有標示什麼
停車廠你停進去就對了
那個沒有標示的就是火鍋店停車廠
大概30米快到的前30米就是火鍋店停車廠這個是學員開的的不是我開的學員開的火鍋店但是我們常去吃
昨天有
昨天有帶那個
新龍牛的
新龍牛
三個帥哥去吃
來各位呢這三個應該認識吧
給各位看一下
昨天帶的這三個
這邊
這裡
首先帶著這三個帥哥去吃
這個是目前是
桃園的俄軍總教練
這是
衛權的俄軍
教練
然後這個張泰山
他們三個來試
就聊聊以前
打球的狀況
然後順便聊一聊股票
聊一下股票
因為其實他們我覺得球員蠻辛苦的
球員蠻辛苦的 而且那個年代其實
他的待遇 說真的現在待遇比較好
現在待遇會比較好一點
那我就跟他們說 現在
我們的交易有分比較刺激的跟比較不刺激的
那比較不刺激的 目前我們用
用一些比較穩健的做法
其實年化20%是蠻簡單的
就是比較簡單的做法就是說
我們也沒有冒什麼風險
大部分都是一多一空把
把那個把部位給鎖住
然後呢因為沒什麼風險可以開槓桿
有風險的你不要開太大槓桿
沒什麼風險就可以開槓桿
所以呢我們用這個沒有什麼風險開槓桿呢
大概可以做到年化二三十趴
按照目前的狀況啦
因為假如明天開始那個
起貨價差單不一樣
我也不曉得剩幾趴
但是呢
觀察這幾個月下來就是年化二三十趴
這個是比較穩健的方式
那比較刺激的
比較刺激的就是像什麼
比較刺激的就是像處置股
那處置股超刺激的
我有一檔股票
我看一下
我有一檔股票今天盤中就一直拉
有一档股票
各位看一下
这个 我有買
他這邊疊的時候我買
這個還沒有算
因為他的籌碼我覺得不錯啦
所以呢 我
再稍微疊下來 雖然還沒有到
到很低的位置 我就先借了
沒有到很低的位置 我覺得因為他籌碼就這樣子
就蠻強的
然後他是算
這個各位看一下
他從高檔175
我們把它歡迎一下
從高檔176呢
回到這邊的低點呢也到154
176到154呢也跌了多少
176到154
也跌了這個
20幾塊
所以呢我在這邊呢我就先接了一些
接了一些
然後連兩天漲
我明天開高就要賣掉了
明天開高就賣掉
因為短線也算漲多了啦
短線也算漲多
所以這一檔這個會出
那最近有些股票
有的都有漲了
像這個1718
1718這邊寫了
處置回檔後漲18
我給各位看一下我們的處置神器
除日神器呢就是會幫我們找一些股票
那各位呢在昨天
昨天
其實昨天我應該要大買才對
但是我們昨天盤中有
有人來家裡開戶
然後中午呢又去參加那個學院的聚餐
所以呢我就
我就沒有好好的買股票
好可惜啊
不然昨天真的還蠻值得一買的
好等一下我先給各位看我的手機
我開一下我的手機畫面給各位看
開始直播
好
開始直播,我們來看一下我們那個
他的處置神器的畫面
這是我手機的畫面
處置神器,這裡
中間處置回答後漲10%
光頂東山再起
中間東山再起
立朋處置回答後漲10%
副頂處置回答後漲10%
吼
那這個利朋主持後跌20%
浪子回頭
浪子回頭是昨天的
昨天的這個盤中
就盤中浪子回頭今天就東山再起了
那中間這一檔也是我們之前也跟各位講的
這個這個籌碼算蠻好的啦
因為這段期間那個主力就一直買嘛
所以浪子回頭讓你早買一點嘛
吼啊東山再起
吼
東山再起早賣點
好不好
所以這邊你看
這邊有下跌讓你買
最低有跌到13.3
其實蠻甜的
今天就14.9
最高
然後他的保證金其實不貴
這個你假如用股票期貨做
這個有股票期貨
用保證金做
因為現在
這個
股票期貨呢
在
在儲置的時候 它會收的比較貴一點
會收的比較貴一點 但也沒有貴太多
這個沒有貴太多 來看一下
昨天有點可惜啊
這個沒有好好的買這一檔
應該狂買它還對
保證金大概
8000塊 昨天大概是
這個7000塊不到
昨天7000塊不到 各位你看一下這兩天
這兩天可以賺到
13.3最低到14.9大概可以賺3000多塊
然後這個是比較刺激的
這是比較刺激的就是
那個做儲置的
所以我就跟他說
你可以學比較刺激的
就是拿一些錢做比較刺激的交易
那剩下的錢呢做比較穩健的
那做比較穩健的我們有可以做
股票跟期貨套利啊
股票跟期貨套利
也可以做股期價差單的這個套利
這個我們每次上個我都會稍微提到
各位有興趣呢 可以看我最近的一些課程
就會教各位啊 因為我知道有些人的
這個
經濟狀況 有的是年輕人
年輕人我就勸他 你就處置好好的研究
研究呢好好玩
你的资金翻得很快因为我们知道很多学员都靠处置都翻了深所以我们就知道那資金翻很快因為我也知道我最近那個資金翻很快安教老師退休組比較穩健的
我就跟他人說你是退休組你算比較穩健的
我會教你一些比較穩健的策略
他就說有空要來選
他每次都說有空要來選
就這樣子
所以這個處置真的很好用
主席真的很好用
今天股奇結算有賺到
哇 這個
今天股奇結算 我覺得很討厭
很討厭
這個政府呢 把一個措施呢
給搞爛了 什麼措施呢
他把期貨1000塊到2500之間呢
他的買賣價
他把他買賣價呢 變成1塊錢一個Ticker
1塊錢一個Tick
哇 這個就
這就不好做了 你知道嗎
1塊錢一個Tick就不好做了
其實比較好做的是5塊錢一個Tick
5塊錢一個Tick
本很薄沒辦法玩
不會啦 我剛剛跟你講的中仙也才7千塊
對不對
你說處置沒辦法玩
你用期貨玩
用期貨玩一個中仙
兩天就讓你有機會賺7000啊
呃...賺3000嘛
兩天有機會賺3000啊
兩天喔
喔...兩天有機會賺3000塊
兩天...然後只要7000塊的成本
喔...就這樣子
所以這個...
這個你看啊...
這邊...起貨這邊流動性很好啊
你要買都買得到啊
唉唷
盤中還有...還有人這樣子砍下來
這邊有什麼好看的
哈哈
便宜賣的
所以
所以你看這個
這個
處置有很多好玩的啦
而且那波動很大
我們做處置呢就是三高嘛
高勝率高周轉高報酬
再講一次喔高勝率高周轉高報酬
那什麼叫高周轉呢
你昨天買今天賣不是高周轉
昨天買今天賣嘛
高周轉
勝率高啊 你去找強勢股回檔勝率高
這個就這樣子啊
高報酬就是你開個槓桿就高報酬嘛那個開槓桿 時的開槓桿不要玩太大開個槓桿就可以玩了
我用處置買鈴骨
哇一萬賺五千喔
49%這麼厲害
這個買鈴骨都可以賺到49%
太強了
那要開個槓桿的話
那個更驚人
那這個
年輕人就是要冒點險
跟各位講年輕人冒點險
冒一點點險
然後抓好時機來做短線
做短線 跟各位講
在這市場上做的最厲害的都是做短線的
再跟各位講一次 市場上做的最厲害都是做短線的
你看到什麼航海王啊 然後去住在那個新一連寢
全部都做短線
我還沒有聽到說有一個人他是
那個從沒什麼本 然後做長線
做短線做到最後當然是有的會變成做長線
因為他的錢變很多了嘛
錢變很多了
短線可能沒辦法滿足他了
他就變做長線
那通常沒什麼本的時候呢
大部分都要靠做短線
靠做短線
所以呢 做短線
做短線是
那個你要變有錢的
其中的一個
很重要的一個方式
因為你做長線
你要變到很有錢
是有點困難
你可能就要慢慢慢慢慢慢變有錢
做長線
那...有可能
就混了老半天還在原來的位置
混了老半天還在原來的位置
可成恢補了嗎?
可成今天沒辦法轉倉啊
一塊多我真的轉不下去
一塊多我轉不下去啊
真的很討厭
好啦 我們就往下講
這九折優惠券在這邊
然後呢
這個全身巧克的討論群
各位討論群在這裡
四個八
各位呢
這個四個八
各位加入一下
我把處置神器的通知呢
傳上去給各位看
因為一般免費版的是
沒有通知啊
付費版的有通知
喔 那我就傳一下
傳一下給各位看
喔 通知
那讓你看他現在的這個這兩天的通知是怎樣
買賣盤捷徑
那個你可以上youtube上面就有的啦
做長線就是要很有錢
真的
做長線真的要很有錢
本大利小
這講什麼
本大 利小 而不小
但是我們做短線的 我們本小啊
本小呢 你就要靠
靠三高嘛
高周轉
高報酬 高勝率
目前 高周轉 高報酬 高勝率
就處置國
處置國呢 就高周轉 高報酬 高勝率
那我們長線策略
因為你有空來上課啦 我們教你
沒什麼風險的年化二三十趴
沒什麼風險喔
不管大盤大漲大跌都不管喔
目前大概就是年化二三十趴
年化二十趴
就是沒什麼風險
只要有風險的
有風險的 那當然年化可能更高
有可能更高 有可能更慘
有風險的就這樣
好 那歡迎各位加一下
這個四個八
四個八
裡面的聊天資訊
是蠻多的啦
各位呢可以去看一下
勝率不重要
賺賠比才重要
對啊這種講法也可以啊
勝率不重要
勝率不重要那你做處置呢
其實勝率蠻高的
勝率蠻高的然後呢
賺賠比呢 我覺得也不錯
因為他有時候彈起來 其實彈很快
好
再來齁
請將Youtube哈指調到最高
直播版權署 理查法跟講說
請不要錄製散播
Youtube哈指比FB好 可以轉到Youtube觀看
直播調標記 使用教學研究
無作相當好
好啦 來看一下上個
上個禮拜中獎的學院
一個真正懂教育的人
不只告訴你哪裡可能有機會
各位讓你知道什麼時候不該出走
謝謝小哥願意把資本心血分享出來
那帶給大家的或許不是某一次行情的獲利
而是一套能夠在市場裡走著更穩更久的思維
謝謝
小哥
我上個內容這個超有料 簡單又好懂
普通是看主力籌碼 全戰是處置策略
這個方法幫我少賠很多淫望錢
每天看PB跟同學的期望
那我從以前亂買亂賠到現在勝率提高很多
謝謝小哥大賠
真的啦 我跟各位講
我們的勝率真的很高
尤其是呢 各位呢 你可以去看一個東西啊
各位呢 你去看一個東西啊 你各位看
這個我們的當沖啊
我們的當沖 要講一下
很多人做當沖都做錯
很多人做當沖都做錯啊
那你可以看一下我當沖
我當沖大部分都是什麼
大部分都是先賣再買
我當沖都是先賣再買
然後呢
我有
很多理由
每次做的時候都很多理由
這個公送大哥入關啊對不對
然後呢
欸
我們今天
欸明天誰贏
明天應該就把這個擺出來
齁 欸來
來給各位投票一下
順便來投個票好了
來 我們那個
讓
各位粉絲投個票
上週台灣要上小哥哥
本週二週三廣告和小進行
欸不錯啊 應該有賺錢
來吧 各位
誰贏啊
這個阿根廷對英格蘭
上贏啊
來 各位可以偷個票
來看一下 看一下誰會贏
來 阿根廷對英格蘭啊
英格蘭阿根廷
我們給小蜜蜍投個票
來看一下誰會贏
哇這個 四族進尾聲了啦齁
這個阿根廷英格蘭
來 我來看一下
現在市場上是大家對
唉呦
哇 勢均力敵欸
我沒有看過如此勢均力敵的
英格蘭的賠率小一點點而已
英格蘭的賠率小一點點
英格蘭贏2.7阿根廷贏3我是看國際的賠優我沒有在下你跟各位講我沒有在下
我只是
我喜歡看數字
就跟看盤一樣
核舉有到2.87
哇塞
這個大家都不知道到底誰會贏
所以我覺得今年四組應該最刺激的一場
英格蘭對阿根廷
來看看誰贏
好
什麼東西
買盤捷徑出現兩打
呃...有時候沒有買盤捷徑我可能就做了
好
這個...讓我一下看
謝小哥的教學
跟無腦反單的分析是不同
是真的能學到東西
最近槌上面
這個一堆在攻擊分析師的
就說
哎呀這個
這個買股票都套牢
買股票都套牢
好那為什麼會有這種狀況呢
其實是
其實是很多股票
我們來看一下
很多股票
這個我們還是給各位看千金股
千金股
那千金股的很多股票都已經怎麼樣
都已經變走空了
各位看一下信話
這都走空了嘛
你連股王走空了 股後走空了
就川湖
古老山還比較厲害
旺溪也準備要走空了 走平了
宏進走空了
台光店也走平了
大立光有點醜
創意也走空了
走空了 這邊月線下完
感覺要走空了
維穎最近還好
聯發科也走空一段時間
那有一堆股票都走空了
那你覺得
光這種這麼強的千金股都走空了
那你認為
分析師只會帶你做多的
他們挑的股票能有多強
他也沒辦法說
從這麼多走空的股票
你可以挑出很多很強的股票嗎
除非都在畫素你啦
都在畫素你跟你講說他手上什麼股票漲很多就跌的不講跌的不講都專門講現在在漲的不然就跌了就跟你講說他在手上什麼股票漲很多就跌的不講都跌的不講都專門講現在在漲的不然就跌了就跟你講說你要這個忍耐
又繼續買繼續買一直買
那其實
其實怎麼樣其實呢你按照
按照什麼東西你可以按照布林通道來做股票
我覺得布林通道最實用
說真的布林通道最實用
像這個比較平行的布林通道
那你就是上下通道
上通道你就記得賣
你下通道可以考慮買
那各位呢
我覺得布林通道真的很好用
我這個看到有些人都講說
這邊跌破了你就要小心啦
那再往下跌
再往下跌它就會走落
那除非它可以站上這個
再往上漲它就會轉強
聽起來好像是有道理
實際講一講它就是個廢話
就在這裡嘛,股價漲這邊要跟你講說
這個位置已經跌破月線了嘛
然後,各位你看
我們用布林通道我覺得真的很好用啦
那你假如用均線來看的話,其實這邊看起來是
是很醜啦,來來,我給各位看一下均線
均線看起來很醜
均線喔
來
唉唷
這個線我把它顏色弄出來一下
來來來來
我把它顏色弄出來
你看這軍線看起來這很醜吧
對不對
然後就跟你講說這軍線都下彎了
對不對看起來就是往下了
啊往下你就說你看他真的往下
除非他能站上這一軍線往上嘛
他才有往上的機會
你聽完好像很有道理 事實上都廢話
阿根廷居然70%
你懂我意思嗎
就是說 你看我再跟你講一次嘛
這個三線往下
三線往下 各位要小心
除非他能站上這一軍線
不然呢 再往下走呢
他的走勢會堪憂
我一聽聽就真的不曉得他在講什麼對不對
你到底是要往上
你到底是要做多還做空 你不知道啊
對不對 你知道這邊有可能會往下嘛 對不對
除非站上之後 他才有機會往上欸對啊 你這樣講好像很有道理好像很有道理除非站上之後才有機會往上明明就站上了 怎麼又跌下來
你懂意思嗎
明明站上了 怎麼又跌下來
你不是說除非站上了才有機會嗎
你看 哇 這三線往上
看起來很有機會了 對不對
站上了就三線往上就很有機會了
聽起來好像很有道理
這邊又跌下來
跌下來又往下
這邊往下
那除非要站上才有機會
不然往下他就後日走勢堪憂
你懂什麼
可是呢 其實你假如用布林通道
其實布林通道
我沒有在湊水啊 各位不要這樣子
你用布林通道其實蠻清楚的啦
蠻清楚的
我們把布林通道線用單純一點
它現在看起來就是一個大型的盤整
你懂嗎
看起來就是個大型的盤整
所以上面呢你可能要賣
底下要買
假如籌碼不錯的話
籌碼不錯就是找買點嘛
那找買點盤整的
這個叫做布林通道平行的
平行的下通道是個買點
你知道什麼意思嗎
上通道就是個賣點嘛
對不對
假如平行的話
所以各位
你要看布林通道
我觉得布林通道很好用啦
看军线我老是不晓得
我到底要做多做空
我真的老是不晓得要做多做空
你真的等到他站上了之后
你做多又跌下来
又跌下来你要做空
你看这个刚刚讲的红说
又跌下来你是不是要做空
你做空他又长上去
长上去你要做多
然后你又扒来扒去的
你又扒到怀疑人生你知道吗
你又扒到怀疑人生
哪
呵呵
除非它漲上去不然就是下跌
對 講均線的就是這種講法
啊我們做布林通道就說
啊就下軌找買點 上軌找賣點
不要想太多
那盤整的時候大概就是這樣子
你知道盤整的時候這樣
欸 滑行客喔 各位看一下
好 各位看那個滑行客喔
滑行客喔 來
這是跌破了嘛 對不對 跌破了
到這邊好 到這邊該怎麼辦呢
其實籌碼還不錯啦
我覺得華信哥第一個籌碼還不錯
然後華信哥呢 我迎接他這個處置
通常處置空的我們比較不愛做啦
空的比較不愛做
這個是跌到淨儲值
通常跌到淨儲值比較不愛買
但是但是butter butter butter
再跟各位講一次喔
華興科呢因為他最近實在跌太快跌太多了
然後他的籌碼又沒有太爛
所以啊
他講得怎麼樣
他講得因為淨儲值有那種
停損的賣壓出現啦
有停損的賣壓出現
就是說
因為不要盡處置嘛
所以我覺得在這邊已經快要出動很多人的停損點了啦
華興科已經有很多融資已經怎麼樣
融資澀澀發抖了好不好
華興科融資澀澀
唉呦
融資已經撿得蠻厲害了
但是
這邊的融資啊
500的590的融資
這邊
600塊的融資到這裡應該要斷頭了
對不對
600塊的融資到這邊應該要斷頭了
所以未來呢 華新科可能會面對怎麼樣
可能會面對像那種
瘋狂的停損的賣壓
舉例來說啦 舉例來說
假設華新科因為處置而跌停的話
而跌停的話那就好玩了喔
那就好玩了
因為處置那個要買的人 他要入金才能買
但是華新科假如因為處置而跌停的話
哇 那有趣囉
那有趣喔 因為處置而跌停的話
然後呢
跌停的話 我會看那一盤 我有沒有能力把它敲開
有沒有能力把它敲開
有可能我集眾人之力 我就可以把它敲開
那個我就會找機會把它敲開
所以我期待 喔 我期待華新哥有停損的紅包
我期待華新哥有停損的紅包
啊你看均線的不要玩了好不好
欸各位
看均線的不要來玩這一檔了啊
沒有你玩的份
好不好沒有你玩的份
看均線就怎麼樣
就全部跌了啊
全部跌了有什麼好買的對不對
這邊沒什麼好買的啦
我們把那個線都把它劃掉
喔
看均線沒什麼好買的啦
怎麼都都得了啦對不對
都跌了啦沒什麼好買的對不對
叫你要停損了對不對
全部要賣掉了對不對
看劇就是這樣子但是我們我們玩土字的 我們看籌碼的我們看籌碼的看買賣力道的變化
那個買點我們就會好好的抓
抓停損哥喔
這檔我覺得有機會有停損哥的紅包
因為這檔從高點跌下來是在跌太多了
這檔從高點跌下來跌太多
這個其實
看軍心有時候真的會八道懷疑人生
因為我不曉得你到底要怎樣
跌破了做多
跌破了賣出
站上去做多
然後又跌破了
你懂的是嗎
最近我們講的被動元件
以前被動元件齁
現在變成
被動元件現在變成
以前是被動變暴動
現在是被動變被套
現在是被套元件
各位看軍線裡都沒什麼好玩的
看軍線都已經整個都破了
好不好 很難玩的
但是看布林通道我們可能還有一點機會
我們來看布林通道
這個真的是有點醜
哎呦
日電貌也快要那個
快要聽牌了
這個吼
被動元件像日電貌我會期待一個東西
期待一個東西叫地板股
然後昨天這個
華新科已經進定版了
但是我今天沒有去搶
昨天華新科進地板
然後我今天沒有搶
今天沒有那個
看一下
台股上市會就漢平了
這個華新科昨天已經地板股
但我今天沒搶 為什麼 因為我知道他今天要進儲治啦
哪有人進儲治前這個搶股票的 當然不會啦
所以呢 我就等他被關了 華新科被關了
那被關了呢 我就要找機會怎麼樣
找機會來敲開跌停
跟各位講 假如華新科跌停被我敲開 我就貼對單給你看
因為那個跌停的敲開 很容易迎來後面的漲停
他就有機會贏來漲停
來看一下
被動一鍵
這個其實這邊我覺得還要很難但是他就有機會贏來漲停他就有機會贏來漲停他就有機會贏來漲停哇這個其實這邊我覺得還要很難但是他就有機會迎來漲停他就有機會迎來漲停來看一下被動元件這個其實這邊我覺得還不錯
還不錯
他算平行的通道嗎
平行的通道
然後籌碼不算爛了
大意反彈了
來來來看一下
被動元件
這個
最早跌的最先談
最早...欸最早跌的最先談
大義呢已經從256.5已經跌到了157
大義打6折了啦
其實我覺得短線打6折已經算是...
算很多了
齁
什麼叫連續跌停?
呵呵 什麼叫連續跌停
痾... 限冊
這叫連續跌停
有沒有 連續跌停
建設我們都遇過了 我們什麼都遇過了啦 有沒有
建設連續跌停
這個我說這一天跌停
這天在跌停有機會敲開我就敲開
我在這天就買了
然後他是
他是在這裡跌到背關喔
在這邊跌到背關
在這裡跌到背關
所以它在這邊跌到背關
背關之後還跌停喔
背關之後還跌停
那我希望是它連續跳跌停
那個會比較好看
從網面怎麼好看這條線呢
這條線是往上還是往下
反正建設我會找機會來
不是建設啦
我覺得被動呢
這個華興科被關齁
今天是確定華興科被關
所以這個被關的呢
我會找機會來買它啦
找機會買它
好
這個
這個是最近的
嗯 狀況
來
所以
這個分析師齁
他很多只能講做多啦
只能講 只能喊多
那跟我們不一樣
我們多空都會做
跟各位講這市場上
留到最後的就是多空會做
還有不開槓桿的再跟各位講市場上呢留到最後的是多空會做跟不開槓桿的你假如開槓桿只會做多很容易畢業喔
開槓桿只會做多很容易畢業
阿你假如多空會做
多空會做
會做多會做空
然後有開槓桿
就比較不會畢業
好
嘗試不同操作
只買0050跟台積電的舒適圈
跟各位講 你只買台積電
我們有一招就是
光用台積電我們可以年花20%
光用台積電 台積電不管漲跟碟啦
大漲我就賺少一點 我就賺20%
大碟我也賺20%
然後我們有一招這樣子
大漲也賺20% 大碟也賺20%
跟台積電有關
大漲賺20% 大碟賺20%
那這一招你看很多人不知道
這一招知道的人不多啦
我在上個時候都有講一下
你現在做台積電
現在做台積電的報酬跟以前的報酬就沒有怎麼樣
沒有像以前那麼厲害的
你看台積電已經混了多久了
對不對
2535在這邊
在這裡混很久了
有沒有
混很久了
好
那可是呢
台積電呢
他這邊不管再怎麼混
我們那一招呢 不管他再怎麼混
混了一年我就拿20%以上
混了一年拿20%
所以我們這邊打算呢 要在這邊放很多資金
放100萬呢 賺20萬 放1000萬賺200萬
放1億就賺2000萬
放個1億的話 還不錯 2000萬
2000萬一天可以花3萬
還不錯
好
2000萬一天花3萬
對啊
欸
不是啦 2000萬一天可以花7萬
那還不錯
好
恭喜中獎喔 你在私訊說你想要什麼娃娃
好 來看學員戰機分享啦
學員戰機 喔這精彩
不錯
藍牙 藍牙是
組織股齁
順達群創合生堂
泰森 唉唷 跟我一樣
泰森我也做很大
國劇齁 這些
精彩富邦聯電
6月份對樣單 這次期貨的賺了2,200
現貨賺1,500 七月份了
七月份了
哇
啊福哥
這個月做梁祖小的轉彎大概賺3500
對吧
好做吧
對啊福哥你就這樣
欸做梁祖小的應該花很少錢
我算一下
做梁祖小的
梁
欸一個20萬40萬
福哥大概花個
50幾萬
50幾萬一個月賺3500
5是幾萬一個月賺3500嗎
所以一年大概賺
你沒有開槓桿
對對對 你還沒開槓桿啦
這個我們交合就是要開槓桿
那槓桿呢 這個
要找一些管道來開
找一些管道來開喔
他的那個報酬率會很漂亮
組織股越來越少了啦
組織股越來越少了
空什麼股票要低調
對 沒錯 要低調
你不能
不能亂空啦
而且不能對外講
對外講其實蠻危險的
福哥沒開槓桿大概就八九趴
八九趴
那我們有開槓桿會到二幾趴
我們有一些特殊管道可以開槓桿
沒有五十萬玩不了
一組大概
一組不用50萬啦
一組大概20幾萬就可以玩了啦
一組20幾萬就可以玩了
這個叫什麼
這個應該是蜂蜜吧
對 老公
老公
我剛才找到東西
嗯
這是晚上的啦
喔,那是怎樣
我這
我這幾歲是沒關係,給我去拿
你會跟他講
啊,這裡有這裡
好
還有這個
這是晚上的,都找怎樣
欸
你這是另外一間客的啦
這個那個
不是
不是北京的
欸,不是
你那另外一間客的
清波路的那裡
對對對,清波路的客
好
不是補著色的
不是
你又在直播欸
好
在直播啊這隻要看著哈哈哈哈你問大家好大家好大家好好啦 你也不要走
好 拜拜
我快點
沒關係 我可能現在起了
我現在起了
好 我再往下看
好 欸 今天的
我跟各位講 今天很有趣啊
欸 今天的
給各位看一個東西喔
今天做了一個有趣的交易喔
來來來來
來
跟各位講啊 這個市場上喔
麻天全金條啦
來吧 這邊
各位 你從這個 你有沒有想到什麼交易
你有想到什麼交易 你知道嗎
你沒有想到什麼交易 說真的
這個看起來很普通
但是呢 你給各位看個東西
近遠月價差呢 是五塊錢
五塊錢喔 也就是說
也就是說
也就是說怎麼樣
立基店的8月份的期貨呢
已經來到了81塊
立基店的8月份期貨來到81塊
81塊喔
81塊 你知道嗎
然後呢 你可以去放空
81塊 明天的立基店
再講一次喔
你可以放空81塊明天立基店
你覺得利基店明天會找到81塊嗎
我不知道啦
但是我覺得布林通道齁
布林通道呢
到84塊其實就有點壓力了
然後他能到84塊嗎
我不知道
我不知道能到84塊
你知道我意思嗎
我不知道他能到84塊
然後我今天就去做什麼事情
我今天呢 我就去空那個價差單
空價差單呢 相當於呢 我去空八十一塊
空八十一塊的利機店
因為我空價差單嘛 就是我是空空那個八月 然後買七月 啊七月到期結算嘛7月結算了所以我空單呢 是在81塊
我空81塊的利基電
然後呢 我盤後去買利基電
我盤後去買利基電
我看一下 我盤後中幾張
我是買蠻多張的啦
我是掛很多張
我盤偷中幾張我看一下
盤偷中4張
利基店今天盤偷有幾張
1971628
然後這邊是
19...唉唷
這還蠻多張的欸
我看一下
反正盤偷我有買到啊
盤偷有買到
就是我去
空期貨
然後掛盤後
空期貨掛盤後
我都可以
都可以做套利了你知道嗎
我看一下這個
等一下
我先
找一個6770我看一下那個
手機的
今天的盤後55張
盤後55張我中4張
拜拜
我這個戶頭就中4張
盤後我這個戶頭就中4張
然後我是去空
81塊的利基點
漲停買不到
喔
對沒錯
那漲停買不到剩空單
明天摘一根不就完了
沒有錯
那個是我的風險
我的風險
但是我覺得
明天再一根的機會
比較小一點
我是覺得啦
明天再一根呢
沒那麼容易啦
我覺得明天再一根沒那麼容易啦
啊 藍亞科也沒有再一根
對不對
華邦店有 藍亞科沒有
你的記憶體呢 並沒有說
並沒有說很強啊
8月份提貨不是7.3我們是駕叉單好不好架叉單是直接來來來來這個
來
我找一下我的對照單給你看
可是這個講了之後
沒關係啦
都跟你們講
明天不要嘎我
拜託啊
明天可別嘎我啊
明天不要嘎我
欸
這個齊全成交回報
哇他是這樣子算喔
哇勒
他把那個損印弄到今天去了
來
這高級套利啊齁
太高級了太高級了
這裡
等一下等一下
我把那個時間給各位看
我把時間弄清楚給各位看
好
来 这边
我的画面的
画面delay了
等一下哦
我先把它关掉一下
我把它斷開連線
再重連一下
這個喔
他的對賬單喔
他是算
我買72塊
因為
他用8月份的去算
算
我把這個給關掉一下
紅臉一下
等我一下
看一下給各位看
因為這個對帳單滿有意思的
因為是
等一下
欸?開不了沒有齁
開不了我直接給各位看
這邊
來各位看一下畫面啊
看這畫面比較清楚啊
剛剛的對帳單
你看這畫面喔
看畫面清楚一點
我們把它拉大一點給各位看
再給各位看一次
這是我的畫面啦
有沒有看到
12.41分12秒
72.3
77.372.01
來來來
給各位看喔
這看比較清楚一點
然後呢他是怎麼樣
他是賣出
他看他是賣出這個
8月份買進7月份
那7月份是買72
7月份買72
那你說7月份沒有72啊
因為他是架差單啊沒辦法
7月份沒有72
但是因為他是架差單
駕叉單的形式他是用8月份的價格去回推
8月份的價格去回推
所以呢 我現在我有
立基電
反正 各位你可以這樣想啦 我今天用這個駕叉單
我就讓我的立基電呢
呃 現在是差5塊錢的成本吧
就變成說 我就提早先賺了5塊錢啦
那明天呢 立基電平盤的話
明天立基電平盤 我大概就賺5塊
那明天利基店涨5塊
明天利基店涨5塊呢
我就打平反正呢 各位你就這樣想這個明天利基店呢這個平盤呢我就打平啦再講一次利基店漲5塊 我打平
利基店平盤 我大賺5塊
利基店漲停呢 我就賠錢
好不好 我就賠錢
就這樣子喔
聽不懂
等一下
等一下 我把我的這個
來來來
太高級了 來用這個給各位看清楚一點
有沒有
唉唷
哇 這個搞不好有人會說這對阿曼是假的喔
呵呵
這個哪有
哪有72.1
對不對 這剛剛截的圖吧 有沒有看到
12.41分12秒哪有72.1
這個是價差單好不好
這個是價差單
價差單 價差單就是
我去賣5塊錢的價差單
賣5塊錢的價差單它就是賣
賣8月份的利基店
然後買7月份的利基店
啊因為他是用8月份為主體嘛
所以利基店呢我變成買72塊
我變成買72塊
所以呢這個
我買72塊我來看一下
因為這個應該會影響到我的平常損益
哇可是你看我的平常損益你就知道我賺多少錢了
好啦沒關係讓各位看一下
這裡
來
我截的圖喔
各位我們的圖都是剛剛截的啦齁
有沒有 這裡啊
你看利基店我是不是賺了
我做了55口就賺了40萬了
光是轉倉喔
以實踐损運40萬
然後呢我現在呢
我有怎麼樣
我有怎麼樣? 我現在我的庫存
我的庫存呢 給各位看一下
我的庫存呢
來來來
我現在我的庫存呢 就有一個利基墊
單是流倉 我的庫存呢有77.3的利基電因為8月份是77.3喔 八月是77.3
所以厲害吧
這個其實不難啊 這真的不難
我再跟各位講個更有趣的 好不好 更有趣
這個是
我再講下去喔 它就是無風險套
再講個更有趣的是
我就去挑權證
那因為
利基電漲停了嘛
對不對
那利基電漲停
那我要去做多 我買不到股票啊
那我是不是可以去挑權證
利基電漲停是不是有的權證
你買不到
你覺得權證買不到嗎
但權證有的還有在報價
發行商不報了
散戶還會掛賣單
這邊是散戶掛的賣單
然後呢我就去挑了一檔全證
大概齁是
明天利基店漲1%的位置
然後我就去買那檔全證
我去買利基店漲1%的位置
然後去空利基店期貨
那個6%的位置
5塊錢大概是6%喔
5塊錢6%
我做了無風險套利
有沒有看到
我當然還有點風險啦
我有點什麼風險
我有那個利基電怎麼樣
我有利基電漲停的風險
所以呢我去買一點他的全鎮做多嘛
然後呢我又去掛
利基電的盤後我又中了幾張
你懂嗎
所以呢我在這邊呢
完成了五風險套利
而且呢我完成了明天呢
明天立基店假如沒有漲5%以上
沒有漲6%
我們算一算大概6%
明天沒有漲6%的話
那麼我就是
我就贏了喔
明天沒有漲6%我就贏
還有一堆隔日蔥啊 欸各位
明立基店不用出貨嗎
欸這個是一個
它不是一個多頭的線型欸
這是一個
這是一個秋天的型態
上面有一堆
嗷嗷代譜的怎麼樣
欸我問你啊
你買在利器店90塊的人85塊的人80塊的人假設你買在80塊已經怎麼樣已經套牢了好多天很簡單嘛你買在85塊的人80塊的人假設你買在80塊已經套牢了好多天很簡單嘛
你買在80塊套牢好多天
前陣子跌到了63塊
明天立即墊80塊
我問你要幹嘛
來 各位來 各位你投票一下
就是你買80塊
跌到了63
天天不是跌到63嗎
買80塊跌到63
明天漲到80塊利基店你要幹嘛
你要幹嘛 再講一次
你買80塊
跌到63
在明天談到80塊
我問你你要幹嘛
這些人 漲到80塊你要幹嘛
序報
最好你會序報
加碼
你不要嘴裡講加碼 明天到80塊
唉唷
好不容易到本錢了 趕快賣掉
趕快賣掉
就等這一刻 解套了趕快賣
好不好
拼了命的賣
跟你講 拼了命的賣
你不要說你加碼 騙笑欸
我沒有看過 好不好
我沒有看過那種
八十塊打八折的
然後反燃到他的
他的解套點
然後他告訴我他要加碼
不可能
一定是趕快跑你知道嗎
他趕快跑欸好不好
好不容易解套了
解套了你還留在那邊
不可能
好啦 來看
學員講得很好
小哥真的很像風輕揚
用獨股九千股
股票是死的 肇事是活的
買價差單也可以玩
賣價差單也可以玩
然後用全正幣
這個好歉咧
對 沒有錯
欸
你漲停你了幹嘛
你漲停什麼事都不能幹好不好
漲停能幹嘛
難道我要跟你吹噓
對 利益漲停能幹嘛
什麼事都不能做
對不對 我們可以用權證來找合理那個
那個 漲1%的權證
就是 相當於利基電漲1%的權證
那我們可以去空6%的利基電
我今天空的利基電是漲6%的利基電
漲6%利基電
所以這種 這種交易啊
這種交易啊
其實你股票跟期貨
期貨跟權證
你兩個可以組合出很多種的交易模式
很多種交易模式
就是你要對這個商品有認知嘛
那我們的
全證進階班就教你這個
你要怎麼去算合理價
對不對
那股票起貨班呢
教你怎麼用價差
我光用價差單
我可以組出一個年化報酬率
超過二三十%的無風險套利單
吼
無風險套利單你知道嗎
吼 所以呢
跟各位講
未來一定會有一段去槓桿
再跟各位講一次
韓國呢已經
扮演
韓國已經演給我們看了
韓國一堆人在那個兩天前怎麼樣
兩天前想不開 為什麼
因為韓國的ETF 兩倍ETF出事
兩倍ETF出事你知道嗎
兩倍ETF出事 兩倍ETF爆倉
韓國的兩倍ETF爆倉
那我們台灣會不會有機會
當然有機會
所以未來一定會有一段去槓桿
因為最近槓桿太多了
一定會有一段去槓桿
所以你做槓桿的人 你一定要多空都有
多空都有 就是我們叫這幾招嘛
多空都有 每一開盤就找一些空彈來做
我們還沒有開始去槓桿
那未來就會去槓桿
那還好 還好跟各位講
我們的政二是那個台灣50政二
那說真的他也不是政二
他避錢全部都是避台子企業
所以說真的 我們的政二比較安全一點
因為我們比較複雜一點
我們的政惡比較複雜一點
再跟各位講 我們的政惡比較複雜
你不要怕我們的政惡 我們的政惡是比較安全
我們的政惡根本不是政惡好不好
你以為他是政惡 他不是政惡啦
這跟各位講了很多次了 我們的政惡不是政惡
台灣五十單向兩倍 他不是政惡
他是做得很像政惡
但事實上他不是政惡
你自己看一下持股比重
你看一下持股比重是什麼東西
持股比重台積電台子旗
台積電台子旗
你們就去買啦
你們就拼命的去買真二
跟各位講
這些正二呢
它每個月轉倉都要付出代價
你們就好好的買真二
我賺的錢就是從這裡來的
好不好
跟各位講 各位好好的買正二
我的無風險套利就從這裡來
你們你們的你們的這個希望就是我套利的所在好不好
一堆人推崇真二
我也很推崇啊
因為大家買真二
我的無風險套利的利潤最高
我的無風險套利就在這裡
因為真二
每個月有四萬五千口要轉倉
四萬五千口要轉倉
都也是厲害
現在期貨價差單一堆正的都是他害的
都他害的好不好
他有4萬5千口要轉倉
他就讓很多期貨正價差都無敵大
台積電正價差
你看每個月轉倉要付20塊
容易嗨
就是一啦
就是所有的投資人
你以為你在玩正二你覺得你很了不起
你不是在玩正二你在玩正十五好不好
你在玩正十五
你在玩正15
人家呢 再把一些錢呢
拿去做別的事 拿去做付買回債券
他是 你買真二
他去大盤商批正15回來
那個台子旗正15
去批正15回來
播一點給你真二
剩下正13呢 跑去買付買回債券
去買債券
我不是要玩刺激的嗎 你去玩債券
債券對啊 你要玩吃雞的 我就買吃雞的啊
我這15倍夠吃雞了吧
我15倍夠吃雞 我剩下拿去買債券就好了
我就條條 你要爭 我到底爭惡啊
對不對
你要爭惡 我就給你爭惡
對不對 條條是從正式 我把它...
把它稀釋 買正式回來稀釋
你要買...你要喝什麼 你要喝水果茶對不對
我拿水果茶巾來
去買個水果茶巾把它稀釋八倍
然後調給你說 這叫台灣50正二
這跟台灣50一根拐頭都沒有
這有台灣50嗎 這有50嗎 這哪50檔
我告訴你 這哪50檔沒有 好不好
他是台股1000拿去稀釋的
台股1000拿去稀釋
拿去稀釋
啊每賺50 這邊台灣50沒啦
這台股1000啦
這台股齊佛這1000好不好
台股1000來稀釋 你知道嗎
套利適合退休族啦我們這裡招認適合退休族啊 真的我可以你招式啊 我只是不能吸金而已我也不想吸金 我自己玩就好了 我幹嘛吸金
但是我們這幾招呢 就是怎麼樣
就年化就是二三十趴
所以你要學的是招式
因為他的招式你學會了
你未來有很多機會可以賺錢
有很多機會可以賺錢
所以我們教你是招式
未來呢 這麼多機會賺錢 它是變來變去
那個標的變來變去
但是你招式會了 你都會
招式會了 你都會
你也不怕它變 你懂嗎
所以我們有一堆人啊
我們有一堆賺錢的方法
太多了啦 教不完啦
我每個月教一次不同的課程
我教一年都不會重複
教練都不會醜補
然後這個學人每個月都還上十幾課
還上十幾課
來來來廣告一下
講到這邊來廣告一下
講個一下
來 各位今天那個
今天呢
籌碼K線年名優惠
這個買再多送一個月全線
連訂閱8388
購買就想低買高賣關鍵分田
我們今天要特別講一個
主題沒有講到
來來來
分田掉下去
來這邊
高手券商
有點當
我的高手券商
有有有
高手券商來
這個自選券商
波段到來
這個三多哥
三多哥最近買什麼呢
喔 最近買了船壺 有點套
喔 松山哥呢 最近買什麼呢
喔 各位看一下
最近買了同心電
喔
627號
松山哥最近買了同心電
欸 布林通道的下跪
還可以啦 我覺得布林通道下跪還可以
喔 啊你不要看軍線喔
看軍線你會有點有點有點痛苦
看軍界有點痛苦
這什麼鬼啊
看軍界你沒想要高評啦
看軍界你老是追高三滴啦
對不對
站上做多 哎呦怎麼跌破站上做多 哎呦怎麼又跌破跌破做空 欸怎麼又漲回去哈哈哈哈喔 跌破做空又漲回去喔所以你用軍線看 你會
你會
你會弄到懷疑人生啊
這跟各位講
軍線你會弄到懷疑人生喔
跟各位講那個
欸
理財寶他去後撤了
很多策略就是
很多策略呢 他們會去做回撤
會去做回撤
那軍線這個策略呢 就是一個
欸 說真的
不是一個表現很好的策略
再跟各位講
均線不是一個表現很好的策略
那儲置股的策略回測數據很漂亮
而且呢 我們的買點
我們的買點比他回測的
比他回測的條件更嚴苛
再講一次喔
我們買點比他回測的條件更嚴苛
所以儲置股的策略很漂亮
所以跟各位講 你用均線來看
你看每次你想做多的時候都被殺下了
你每次做多的時候
我都在空
因為這天我就空了
為什麼這天要做空
你講站上軍線要做多
三個都做多
不是要往上嗎
那就是要做空
籌碼就是偏空
你懂嗎
就是你用軍線來做齁
你軍線一定會做到一檔很漂亮
但是有好多檔你都會被
但是呢 你說啊我就會遇到那一檔啊
那一檔真的很少
其實很多股票都會來這邊
就是來這邊巴來巴去的
所以跟各位講
其實我覺得最好的策略齁
就是最好的這個技術齁
技術線型我覺得
這個看技術指標裡面我覺得最好的
還是布林通道
最好的我覺得還是布林通道
這個布林通道就很好理解嘛對不對
很好理解嘛 對不對
平行的通道上面你就不要太看多
這算平行的嘛
啊底下你可以看多
啊最近呢 松山哥有買這一檔
賠一億
松山賠錢你不賠
啊這一檔再起你是誰
我不曉得會不會再起 我不知道
我沒有替他保證喔 我沒有
我不知道會不會再起啊
但是呢 我們都會看一下說
欸 這個最近主力在買什麼
啊為什麼買那麼多
買2000
買2000丁買4、5億 對不對
買451
會不會想到什麼東西
這有開布林嗎
這沒有 再沒有開布林
但是算平行
開布林就是一根長長的
然後就往下了
然後一直沿著下跪
然後它的這個貸寬太寬了啦
這個貸寬太寬了
211到290
這太寬了啦
這貸寬80塊已經大概40%了
所以這個我覺得要開布林
還沒那麼容易
302到224短線也跌了
也打了7折
看起來還不錯
啊這個就是
我們沒事就會從飛行教授裡面去看一下
最近呢這個
阻力在買什麼
富邦經典 富邦經典在買經濟喔
唉唷
最近又買經濟喔 哇這個真的套了
唉唷 又來了
經濟喔 不錯喔
這個大盤商套老了
啊
大盤商套老
大盤商應該賺蠻多的
喔又來了
大盤商最近買了很多啦
最近是主力大戶都在套喔
連主力大戶也在套
對不對 主力大戶啊
這個點真的賣得沒有很漂亮
這邊最高追的有點醜
最高追有點醜
然後這也是一個平行的布林通道
這邊算平行的
有點要壓縮
這種平行的通道下通道呢
主力有在買的話可以考慮要不要買
那最好的是怎麼樣
最好是他有地盤股
有地盤股會更好
有地盤股更好
好啦
所以這個
這很好用啦
八月份全證進階班
我們在教你全證
全證搭配古期
我們上幾個月講古期
未來講全證
全證搭配古期
全證進階班
這次呢 我就會講很多的招式
全政有很多招式可以做啦
我今天就買
就買全政 我就買利基電的
我買那個漲一趴的 漲兩趴的
我都賺錢啦 都套利啊
漲一趴 漲兩趴 都套利 都算套利
好啦 跟各位講
我們厲害囉
這個喔 這個課程喔
上完三堂
上完三堂類似的課程
我们会送全套一个月全套一个月是含处置神器的喔而且处置神器很贵的喔我们上完三堂课程会送全套一個月全套一個月是很處置神器的喔現在處置神器很貴的喔我們上完三堂課程會送全套一個月
我們現在上課喔
幾乎常常都是滿場
都滿場欸
從一月份滿到八月份欸
每一場都滿場
一月份滿到八月
喔
這個除了上課有料以外
當然就是那個
還有送軟體
所以有的人想說 他每個月來上
他的軟體就可以沿透白 沒有錯啦
我們就是這麼優惠嘛
這個價格又便宜
有興趣的歡迎去報名參加
好啦 這個
工商一下
最後呢 喜歡今天直播
我們先來看喔
來 各位看一下我們的交易筆記本
交易筆記本喔
九折優惠券在那邊
交易筆記本 這是全台最多人訂閱的
之前呢是
是3000多嘛 跟各位講 有
交易筆記本就是 你做的好 訂閱的人數多
然後退訂的人數少 它的人數就會增加嘛
訂的人數多 退的少 人數就增加嘛
訂的少 退的多 人數就減少嘛 對不對
那我們來看一下 最近到幾個人呢
最近到幾個人
哇 来来来 最近到4000人了
从3000多到4000多了
到4000多了
那每天都要回答学院的问题
小秘书的也在这边
小秘书这边 关键筹码
这边
小秘书的也不错 各位有兴趣可以订
好 工商一下
好啦
这个留存率很高啦
好啦 那最后呢
呃...最後...這個...
喜歡今天直播歡迎按讚訂閱
留恩觀看心扯
我們抽景品娃娃來
景品娃娃齁
我的學員都猜阿根廷會贏啦
我們今天呢就來看是阿根廷贏還是英格蘭贏啦
阿根廷還是英格蘭
好
這個...
本身有概念的可以去上
上進階班
這全正概念你可以去上我的以前的一些
歌友仇必報的節目啦可以先去看一下或者你可以先去看回看那個全證的基礎班那這是全證基礎班我們講的很基礎那後面呢
後面這個進階班呢
會講很多進階的招式
其實全證有很多招式可以做
很多招式可以做
其實每天呢
每天都有很多招式可以做
真的啦
其實你應該好好的學全證
全證跟股企搭配下來
其實我覺得一些退休人士
他也可以來做這個
因為股票漲停的股期不一定漲停
股票漲停的股期不一定漲停
那這中間呢其實都有利潤可以套
像今天他就有套利的空間在
這市場上呢不是那麼的有效率
好不好
這市場上不是那麼有效率
所以有些人呢他是靠內線嘛
因為他不是那麼有效率
所以靠內線可以賺錢
但是那些說靠內線可以賺錢的
最近這種盤是他還是賠得一塌糊塗啊
對不對
因為靠內線可以賺錢
大概是大多頭會賺
那空頭呢 還是會賠啊
還是會賠
那所以呢 靠技巧賺錢呢 那就厲害了
那我們這一派呢 全部都是技巧派
我們這邊全部都是靠技巧
我這靠技巧賺錢 我沒有什麼
我沒有什麼那個
跟這些投資公司互通永無啦
我沒有
我沒有什麼內線消息 沒有
我只能看籌碼
然後我只能這個一步一腳印 靠這些技術
那靠這些技術能不能賺錢呢
可以啊
欸各位啊 我們的績效是遠遠的贏過很多人
懂嗎 我們績效贏過很多人
6月份績效 6月份對不對
而且這個是 6月份已經不好做了
6月份很多人都做到賠錢了 我們還是做到賺錢了
等到7月份完再給各位看7月份
7月份還真的不好做
但7月份到目前為止還是賺錢
7月份到目前為止還是賺了
也是賺8位輸 7月份到目前為止
也就是說我們這一招
這一招
這股票期貨全政
這些招式啊
你把它學會融會貫通之後
其實股票市場上蠻有趣的
好啦
最後呢 全政進階班
台中長是幾要上課
上面很多答案啊
那我們來抽獎
抽獎
來來來來
線上亂數產生器
各位 那個上課要報名的趕快報啦
因為後面常常就滿了那我的時間也可以開的場次呢就是一個月就那麼三場那個滿了可能就得聽
聽影音也可以啦
好啦
來來來來
沒事看東京的房子
抽
7號21號
21號
好啦 7號 21號
這個是抽獎啦
哇 這一夜
很大的 這邊都比較貴
前炒戰步行八分才八
這在一千多萬而已
哇 東京有個房子
這蠻不錯的
好啦 那我們今天的直播呢
就講到這邊啦
就講到這邊
喜歡直播的呢
喜歡直播的 歡迎幫我按個讚 按個讚 訂閱訂閱
訂閱一下啦 欸各位 求訂閱
拜託 幫我按個訂閱
讓我可以拿到十萬的獎牌啦
我的訂閱人數快十萬了 喔 快十萬了
請幫我
這個 按個訂閱啦
哇 目前9.65 耶 9.65
再三千五百人
我就有一個
YouTube的獎牌啦
歡迎各位
歡迎各位這個
按個訂閱
好 感謝各位訂閱
那我們今天的直播就講到這裡了
夜盤殺下去了
欸我剛剛是賣啊
對對對 我剛剛是賣捏
彈上來我賣 對不對
殺下去我可以買
開心了
來看一下 我看一下我的夜盤
夜盤剛剛賺多少
唉唷 賺7萬
賺13萬耶
夜盤賺到13萬 三口賺13萬 我來看一下
不錯不錯
喔 358點 買買買買
4571 買進
沒事 買一下
買一下啦 這個急殺都是讓你買一點的
反正沒差
我有利接電的空單嘛 對不對
我買一點Big Sian 對不對
疊那麼多 你以為利基電會彈多高嗎
很難嘛 對不對
所以我現在 利基電的空單
我就可以用台子旗嘛
台子旗疊那麼多
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕